[Music]
has since been removed so please do
remember to turn your microphones off
when you have finished speaking or
failing
[Music]
attendances
and apologies have been received
two discussions from memphis
item three is declarations of interest
are there foreign
um minister meeting on the 21st of march
this year um can they be agreed please
thank you 95 as matters from council or
overview and scrutiny committee
yeah i don't know the
note that work will be needed to be done
by the council to assess the
viability of some of the recommendations
that's clearly obvious
that you would need to do
[Music]
i believe there are signs
and
i think
there are some issues i believe with the
provision of temporary
toilets
[Music]
and i think
the question of negotiating something
policy
is an interesting one
um
and actually
you know negotiating where you can
actually stay within
a short period of time
so there are a
number of issues but i think he
responded in the way
that
[Music]
but at the same time there will be work
done um
[Music]
i think
we
what i would say on this this is a
very complex issue we receive a lot of
complaints from residents about
disruption when members of the chubby
community
arrive in their localities many
residents warmly welcome and work with
um
these people when they arrive and that
is of course appreciated but we do know
that there can be considerable
to look at disruptions ways which
council can help um travelers find the
safe space to hear from trafford and to
minimize that disruption in our
communities i know that
we have been
[Music]
particularly um
we we have had a particularly high
number of instances in recent months
particularly in the m41 and lots of
areas i know cancer hardly have um a
couple of issues
and i know that other members have
similarly services and something that i
think would be approaching the right way
can be a win-win working more
sympathetically
about
um
the impact on our residents um so we
will as i say bring a further report to
the executive later this year
which i think as i say on a very
difficult
issue are very well called out and give
us considerable ground for which to work
so thank you councillor
for
questions will come out more widely
grow
um thank you
um i guess i'd like to thank the past
and finished with um
um
[Music]
there was quite a good attendance
and it is the responsibility of this
council as part of helping actually
assess the need for
travelers and i just wanted to make sure
that the local plan which is now
emerging um
[Music]
we don't have any provisional sites for
travelers as far as they know
um which leaves us kind of
in a place where we can't offer that
provision when generously connected
and i was just wondering whether this
council is seriously going to look at
whether it can provide provision in the
future
um
and i think this is such a crucial issue
because
the
the gypsy rover and traveling institute
one that
does experience a lot of
prejudice it doesn't
experience a lot of
neglecting in terms of the services that
are provided before
so i just wondered whether those
councils
yes we will um there is a specific
recommendation as it pertains to
the
local plan and scoping out how we can
include this and meet our statutory
obligations um to the traveling
community as part of that work so it
will be taken forward in the local plan
there is considerable further work to do
on that piece
of workflow
in the months ahead
but it will absolutely be any part of
that and
um
do we have um any idea at the moment of
the cost for um for the site that you
know we've been visiting on a temporary
basis
has has anything been
no
looking at richard here i suppose i
started
of
um managing traveling community rather
than traffic without
[Music]
we don't have a specific budget um
so anything any cost that the people
responding to
is
an additional cost because
it runs into the thousands so that is
variable just depending on the number of
candidates
that we have throughout the year
that would need to be balanced with the
um the current cost of the cleanup plus
office's time and you know to do with um
uh you know the legal team which i've
had to deal with that on every time
uh
um
[Music]
that we are currently um bearing um and
laying laying that down against any
recommendations that would cost
implications moving forward
thank you okay so oh
um
i was chairman of the gypsy hollywood
traveler um scrutiny
group that trusted finished the look to
this just to put a little bit perhaps
put your mind at rest about uh
negotiating stopping negotiating
something doesn't necessarily require a
permanent site so in as much it doesn't
necessarily require an identified
um aside on a permanent basis and what
other councils for example at least
attempt to do is to find spaces around
the border that are suitable but not
necessarily long term and the advantage
of that is it doesn't have the output in
terms of finance so we don't have to buy
the space that we will use irregularly
with visiting gypsy travel around the
group um but we might use spaces around
the ball that are currently unused and
the advantage that has is not only it
preserves the finances of the council
but it also means that no one particular
set of residents
have to come to terms with the
traveler's site being on their doorstep
it might be anywhere across the borough
so if we decide to go down on the go
shake stopping route it will look at
places where we can um discuss with the
communities who are traveling
uh and negotiate a stop in time so it
might be perhaps four weeks or something
then the services that we can provide
will kick in
so hopefully it
it
um it was the travellers it works for
the residents it works for the offices
in terms of the fact that once that
negotiation is in place um
then they are just waiting for the
negotiation
time spent at that site to move on um to
come along and obviously it does help in
terms of the cleanup because we're
hoping that facilities we can provide
um mean that there is no end result
um
where the site is left in a complete
state it would also offer a lot of
racial residents report because the
facilities that we provide hopefully
will be branded with stratfor branding
which suggests to anybody who's passing
by that the site is being managed is in
hand so um
it is a brief report at the moment
um
suggested it will come back to scrutiny
with a lot more information but if you
do have any questions just suggest
please feel free to get in touch because
we're very happy to help you out we've
done quite a lot of research
um and just to say for everybody the
context of this is also in the face of
the oncoming police planning sentencing
bill
and that does mean that we really need
to move
with caution in terms of
um what we can afford to do and what we
can do that's best for them for our
communities and our visiting visiting
travelers we also need to bear in mind
that traveling communities are about to
be hit with a circumstance where if they
stop anywhere they could be fined they
could be sent to prison and they could
have their homes removed from them so it
really is an issue you know it would
make me personally extremely sad to see
ancient communities
effectively destroyed in that way so
what i was hoping when we originally set
about the task initiated was a
managing our residents expectations and
making sure that traveling communities
don't um distress them in any way
providing for travel communities but
also making sure that this isn't the end
of what is a heritage community so thank
you very much
thank you
i'm here
to
tonight
our current citizens misuse contract for
a further
two years and two months
um the current contract which we run the
salford and bolton expires next january
so if you agree tonight the um we will
extend the contract until march 2025.
if we don't do this we'll have to embark
on the procurement process
and
um in the next
year trafford along with other
english las is expecting to receive
additional funding for the next three
years
to support the government's 10 years
drug strategy
which was published last december
so the existing contract is innovative
and it's rated outstanding services
rated outstanding by the cqc
and so rather than go for the risks that
procurement brings
and this would provide consistency of
service delivery
and it would improve the substance
misuse treatment and recovery program
improve service quality and capacity
improve health outcomes and reduce drug
and alcohol-related deaths
so i'm seeking approval tonight please
thank you council card for any questions
or comments from members of the
executive council
definitely support this report i think
um
we need a degree of stupidity um that
we've had
cases that have not come forward and
increases in alcohol and subsidism
issues so as councilman carter states
the service that
provides services for us is an excellent
service and to create instability
postcode i think would be really
detrimental to the residents of trafford
so totally supportive
thank you thanks for having me any other
questions or questions of the executive
no more broadly counsellor
thank you um clearly dealing with two
difficult areas with
massive potential for knock-on effects
and spirals of decline for individuals
so
certainly it's an important
area to to deal
properly with
and
wearing all of my town hall hats
i'm very supportive
of this funding
it makes sense
to
continue in in this way
um i mean i think it is important that
that funding is ring fenced for the for
the full term
um it's
it's not an insignificant sum of money
but in the big picture
um
it's not a huge sum of money so it is
important to
to have it there um
revenge for for the purpose
i i wondered if um
it is
appropriate for us to look for some
sorts of kpis for the work that is being
done i know it's a difficult
area um particularly in terms of the
um
the individuals involved and the
matters that are being treated with
um but perhaps some delicate kpis could
be
put together
and perhaps drawing comparisons with the
two other partners in in the scheme
quite different boroughs and it there
may just well be some messages that
could emerge from
from those sorts of comparisons so um
with those comments i'll just reinforce
um
from our point of view we're very
supportive of the continuation of this
funding
thank you
um we already have some kpis
in
which we can let you have i'm assuming
yeah um because obviously the contract
will need monitoring but i also think
what he said about comparing to the
other authorities we need some
benchmarking in there as well don't we
to see where we are
so um can we say that we'll bring that
back in in a few more times
any other questions or comments
no okay the recommendation is to approve
the extension contract
please
a great deal of work has been put into
these bids and requires offices for
their true lender's efforts over the
past few months
the scope of these debts is broadly set
out in the report by our summarized
embroidery
regenerating part in turn focuses on the
remodel departing to leisure centre as a
community-wide hub for health and
well-being
it will see investment into key sporting
and youth facilities in the area with a
strong focus on skills and health
connecting culture
arts council england identifies trafford
as a high need area in terms of cultural
investment
this bid focuses on the refurbishment
gate this will see our very popular
local studies section we housed into a
bespoke facility creating a cultural
destination of first class educational
and community space
this bit also identifies with modern
work to the water side which will
enhance exhibition space and include
access and linkages with sail library
connecting culture will also develop a
traffic heritage trail investing in and
connecting historic parks and centres
and linking with wider active travel
plans
and our third bid is for transforming
the sail town centre which would enable
us to implement public ground and active
travel improvements to the town centre
including for work to school
this much-needed investment will be
welcomed by residents and businesses and
i
will complement regeneration efforts
being led by our private sector partners
and support our ambitions for sale
russia centre
i consider these to be three entity bids
all very worthy they support economic
growth well-being and respond to the
need for investment into our communities
town centres streets and parks
in a different approach usually taken on
a morning public sector funding the
lending up fund has an application
process that is based around
parliamentary constituencies
so i would like to thank green mp and mr
gray and brady mp for their support so
far i think it will be important moving
forward
in conclusion i would like to raise a
note of caution if there is no
guaranteed traffic will be successful in
what would be a very competitive process
between councils
i am very confident that we're putting
forward three strong comprehensive gigs
that will make a real difference to our
residents so on that basis i'm asking
executives for a good interested mission
thank you
about the scale of ambition with these
three bids i think they are three very
different bits but they are three very
very
important bids i think um i'm
particularly excited about the parchment
and
lovely look that actually this is a part
of our where healthy life expectancy so
years of healthy life was 16 years lower
than bowdoin which is only four and a
half four miles
away at the same time as somebody who um
supposedly playing a sort of unofficial
interest went to nursery in modeling
gate know that that is a building that
is both potentially beautiful and
formally musical but also in a desperate
state
at present and then finally i think the
cultural bid
taps into
wider work that we are doing on a
culture strategy across trafford i think
forever such as ourselves it is overdue
um
and it's really really pleasing to see
that come forward finally as a primary
war council i would just say that it is
some time since the council
and directly invested into its assets
within sales town centre other than
perhaps the magistrates court we have an
exciting plan
for
sailor legislator moving forward but
this would be the missing piece of the
jigsaw school road in particular is
looking i'm tired to say the least i'm
having spent some time challenging
non-private sets of partners in sales
down center council of banknote council
relatives and myself and it would be
wrong with us not to suggest that this
would give us an opportunity for the
council to match the scale now of their
ambitions and work in the town centre um
but i just wonder if there are any
questions or comments from any of the
members of
i'm sure
that he's more deserving than
potential so i i'm really welcoming this
employee welcome on three days but i do
want to make a specific point in
specific classes
and green space and i'd like to thank
those offices
after this um because of some extent to
keep us quite
come to councillor boston and we're any
questions or comments more broadly
hey chad uh my question is going to be
around the uh on facebook
it's i mean the the appointment that the
government here 4.8 billion pounds of
the support and time sectors of high
speed domination local transport
projects basically and yet
you know we seem to
risk the bid own one bit uh which i
thought you know would have been
something that you just devoted to the
fact that we've been much
much invested into the area and the
administration is constantly being
critical of not getting enough
government investment
and the reason being for not being able
to put the bidding round one was due to
the time constraints and in submitting a
bid for the first round or funding
requiring detailed information and
customers yet
the government outcome of the first
round of bidding which was closed in
october last year
uh there was 104 councils submitted
successful bids which averaged 16
million pounds and each bid was
capable of bidding up to 20 million
pounds
so that doesn't include the number of
councils perhaps still in their base
so
i'm just hoping that you know these
these
i just want to know whether our council
is something special for others
absolutely
the wrong one so i'm just hoping that
you know this round two
is going to be successful
so
kind of adjust the question as to why we
were named
the deadlines were extremely timely
councils that submitted each other
around
at off-the-shelf schemes
um that were easily adaptable to the
application process and that's not
something that happened all these
didn't have anything off the shelf to
provide
within the demos for that first one
other questions or comments
okay thank you lina um
i'm glad to see that the bids three bids
are very diverse in nature
and um pleased to see that the 125 000
that was provided to develop the bigs
and has has been used and you know and
i'm looking forward to you know to see
you know sort of more
meats on the skeleton if it just does go
through
um could it just ask would be any other
type of consultation that can be
considered in the future to encourage
more public responses i know it's it's
always quite difficult whenever we have
consultations with
groups all over the borough and there
isn't always a big response from people
and i think
usually a lot of work goes into
consultations
and
i think we're always left a little
underwhelmed by the the few people that
that happened to you know to put in
their views whether or not would be
negative or positive
um i just just thought i'd like to let
[Music]
transportation
and we are currently on citizen space
inviting people
um
you know it's a very
competitive process
just just very very briefly echo
slightly overcast but you're saying the
nature of these government funding
schemes often involves quite short
turnaround times thus they do favor
off-the-shelf schemes
players possibly
if in the future we could look at
initiatives or a ferrari to
actually develop more on-the-shelf
schemes in collaboration with all boards
all members so that we don't continually
get caught off the hoof
because the government tends to do these
short turnarounds and would be wonderful
to have more on the shelf schemes thank
you
it's something this is something that is
actually coming up quite a lot of growth
manchester at the moment council for us
and it's an important point and we
as
have
discussed
manchester united's options particularly
on the transport funding side for cf
germs providing capacity into councils
as well as one example it is
a persistent frustration i think that
all councils a that we have a bidding
process that puts councils against each
other to secure women from input b that
we also have these absurd time scales
that we are so often faced with to come
forward with transformational schemes
that will make a lasting difference in
our community it will strike me as
something that one would want to get
right so everything answers the question
is yes we will be looking at what we can
do to bring forward speeds thought i
would be lying if i said that there were
not significant capacity issues in the
council to do that um and so other great
amounts of local conversations are
ongoing about how we can have balance to
local authority uh particularly economic
growth and provide support as needed and
to develop
these sorts of proposals it is
challenging to know what the given
slogan will be from one month to the
next so we won't always have something
appropriate it does make sense to i
think certainly have a list of potential
um schemes i don't know if liz will
richard wants anything to do but i'm
just reflecting there what is a common
frustration across manchester and the
solutions that we have about how we
might move that forward
down
we did an awful lot of work actually on
around one base we worked on these
schemes our care from potential valve
groundwater bits but i believe at the
time from the consultants
was that they were not sufficiently
progressed at that point in time
um
[Music]
is
[Music]
a really difficult time
any more questions or comments
no there are four substantive
recommendations that allow us to move
forward
with these kids can they be agreed
[Music]
and colleagues will be aware that as we
continue to face the precious and we
continue to look at selling leads that
don't impact on frontline services or
affects the most vulnerable presidents
or businesses
so tonight i'm seeking
to consult on reviewing the empty
properties related discounts
i'd like colleagues to note the
information in the report including the
total amount rewards costing va 2122
which is almost a million pounds
and how we compare with other gm workers
thank
said then i have two questions then two
more
in-depth questions um
what's the quantity of the 958k between
the two effectively two discretionary
schemes
um and secondly
yes that's correct it's probably
obviously going through consultation at
this stage and firstly i'm going to ask
graham to elaborate on the question
the the world quantum is
[Music]
um
so we
completely appreciate the the situation
councils and broadly supportive of
the change and i think all my quest
question i don't know this is probably
going to be covered as part of the
consultation
a maybe expensive property but you
haven't got a large amount of savings
variables paid council taxes there's a
time to sell any property which at the
moment is between four and six months of
average and it's just if we've talked
about those consultations
[Music]
is difficult this would be a difficult
decision if we didn't take it to the um
to the final policy but actually as
you're aware we are facing continuing
the financial pressures of local
authority and we're looking at ways that
impact on frontline services police so
this
the recommendations that we've received
the consultation
[Music]
thank you
okay item nine is council roscoe budget
monitor four twenty
twenty one
this amount has been transferred to
reserves as we continue to manage
particularly our demands services which
are you know continuously to be
challenging lots of reasons why they are
as they are so children's placements
homeschool transport
and we've also had a short form in the
strategic investment program however
that did still contribute six and a half
or over six
and also ask members to notice the
specific section of the report relating
to inflationary crashes you'll see that
we go into details of some of the
forecasts we
are making at the moment that is a
continued focus for us as students
change
in that area and we made a decision to
create an inflation risk reserve this
year as we're trying to safeguard our
finances against what we look
like is going to be a double-digit
inflationary figure
finally i've asked police to turn the
final capital out to a position in our
decision to create a new capital program
board which is intended to improve
project management and the delivery of
our capital priorities so i'm very happy
to ask for that you know
thank you councillor ross any questions
or comments of the executive
questions or comments more why do you
cancel it
in terms of launch properly uh it works
how much normal facility has been taken
is that
that's something that we can get to here
rise in fuel costs continue throughout
this year would that be able to absorb
the cost that
we all know anyone who kills their tank
up at the moment the pressures that um
i'm a bit more pessimistic about the
inflationary outlook obviously you have
a um a foreign exchange which is 30
years along with other things there's a
shortage of
labor
um
the situation the conflict in ukraine
lots of things are adding into this
information we spiral
and things like energy budgets
has accounted for in in the report
itself
i suspect things will get worse in terms
of inflation i hope not i hope i'm wrong
in that position but i expect they do
and we will obviously be keeping a very
close eye as this next year progresses
on inflationary pressures and what we
may need to do
in order to balance our budget this is
this is very much a start but i'm
incredibly mindful of it i know that you
can see two speaking colleagues in the
room about nearly well last course we
were talking about inflation before it
became an actual
issue so i like to think that we're
ahead of the game and we'll just keep
you know keep a very slight
track on the challenges that we face
because it's going to be a difficult
year it's the first time in um well a
generation that we've had in place with
crashes like this we're also faced with
the uh the
base right going which obviously hasn't
ever impacts of india
which is along with lots of marine
difficulties so um rest assured we will
continue to work incredibly hard as a
administration just as we have to
improve it and some of the things that
we face in the last few years yeah thank
you
any other questions or comments
thank you leader um
general capital programme on page 126 uh
children's social care it mentions
foster carers accommodation improvements
it's 32 000. it's not a large amount of
money but if a carer owns their own home
and an improvement done
do we as a council
get any money back when the property is
sold or is it is it just
part and parcel of the carers
and
providing
certain
types for
the children that young people look
after
thank you
[Music]
is quite difficult we also came closely
with one of our housing providers to
look at whether we can um develop
housing solutions to increase our
sufficiency and fasting errors
okay thank you
and just just secondly um
on page one two nine uh
section 35 uh to do with again
children's services it's in relation to
high school um money's being spent and
supporting decarbonisation works do we
know
what that actually covers
well the
decarbonisation works were things that
we
will be one of those that have gone
through this process i don't know
and this annual report both of which
members have um in front of them so you
will all be aware that the council
resets our priorities last year to focus
on reducing health inequalities
supporting people out of poverty and
addressing our climate crisis
and the parameters that we report
pertain to those
particular priorities i'll just draw out
a couple of highlights
um from each of those sections so
firstly around reducing health
inequalities such as reference
engagement service passing its matrix
assessment which is a nationally
recognized quality mark and that does
include our streets or keyword team and
the connections and talk about service
so particularly welcome that as well as
a consultation review our mental health
services for adults to ensure that we
are on the right track there in terms of
supporting people after poverty there is
a plethora of work going on here and
much of it excellent but i would
particularly say um how proud i was to
open about the court our new social
housing and
in village ward and the first new build
social media council in the borough for
over 10 years and secondly just to
reference the excellent work going on
through the poverty truth commission
several traffic policy strategy
workshops having taken place that sadly
looks as though it will be an
increasingly important part of our work
over the next couple of years given the
possibility crisis um that is starting
to end us and then finally on addressing
our climate crisis and point to just a
couple of particularly exciting
developments so um the included electric
vehicles introduced by the long traffic
partnership
council which is saving nearly 21 tons
of parliament per
and the national recycling award that we
wouldn't call that small campaign of the
year um for the paper blues campaign
encouraging people to improve their
paper recycling i just would say as well
and again this is in the report and or
hasn't naturally spotted
any of those headers but the streptotom
center transformation muscle plant has
been approved and this has been a major
priority for the council and to see it
move forward with the ground commission
um is really exciting allowing us to
proceed with what is an extremely
ambitious regeneration and proposal
mongol review
in stratfor there is a full performance
update attached
and i'm happy to address any questions
members may have um there but also just
to reference the annual plan that is the
annual update which is included and also
for information which again tracks
against the three corporate priorities
and again very happy to answer questions
and that members may have on that so
on that basis um i will move the report
are there any questions or comments from
members
[Music]
uh richard are you able to give an
update on that i'm sure council will
leave what you said as well council
jerome will um take that away for
richard
yeah we we are working on uh
information requests as
noted on page 196
and about the timeliness of the requests
and seems to be
dropping the percentages with dropping
them over the period of time
most public authorities take about 20
days to respond from day one and i just
wondered um if there was if this was
just a temporary issue
or if um you know things are going to
improve in the future thank you
yeah thank you
we will give you a
full update on that it is an issue where
we have had some challenges and i think
that we will accept that
integration
um
and i think council ross has been um
yeah i think it's a good observation
any other questions or comments
with the listeners around um you know
carbon neutrality and greening um
okay so um those reports are for
noticing both the course support and the
annual and they definitely please
all right thank you um urban business i
have none and the execution resolution
is not required so that brings us to the
end of the meeting thank you very much
any counselors
please come in
thank you i do have one quick question
um
[Music]
consultation results will be considered
by the trafficking committee in june
2022
a
absolutely
[Music]
that brings us to the end of the meeting
thank you very much everybody